what happened with iran with the
alarming threat
to fly plane into capital investigation
they got a recording a threat heard by
multiple air traffic controllers in new
york
to fly a plane into the u.s capital on
wednesday to avenge
the death of iranian terrorists rasam
soleimani in is being investigated cbs
reported
wednesday audio of the threat which was
obtained by cbs news went as follows
and it was a digitized voice recording
we are flying a plane into the capital
on wednesday suleimani will be avenged
the threat heard by american air traffic
controllers was made monday
the one-year anniversary of soleimani's
death
so you know it's unclear who sent the
threat cbs4 wednesday morning while the
government does not believe the warning
of the attack is credible
it has been investigated as a breach of
aviation frequency cbs has learned
while the government does not believe
the warning of an attack
is credible what do you mean while the
government does not believe the warning
of an attack is credible on a one-year
anniversary
you best believe it's a credible source
if they're saying it on a one-year
anniversary you don't just say
oh it's just somebody playing a prank
it's so funny
you've got to take this stuff seriously
so what do you think is going to happen
here with this well you've talked we've
talked about this before
about basically the mindset of the
leaders of
iran you remember what i said about it
on the video that we did 11 and a half
months ago
remember what i said will happen do you
remember what i said what happened
you said something watch what he said
what did i say will happen with this
they're very uh like with rituals and
anniversaries important anniversaries
you know what i said
i i hope you go watch that and see what
was said here's what i said
i said the day after if trump loses and
biden gets elected
that day they will plan their attack
i said the day they know trump's no
longer
in bidens in they will plan their attack
because they're not afraid of biden but
they're afraid of trump because trump
took a soleimani
they're gonna avenge soleimani there's
no question about it
they're going to avenge soleimani that
is not going to be i have a little bit
of a different opinion i'd love to hear
it i think it's a diversion tactic i i
think you keep this revenge for
solomonia out there
we're going to kill trump we're going to
fly planes into your uh capitol building
keeps conversations off about them
getting what they need to build a
nuclear bomb
or getting joe biden to be favorable to
them going forward i think
this is an awful lot of talk you know
with not a lot of action i'm not saying
they're not capable of doing it i'm not
saying they're not pissed off or they're
they're planning something my my opinion
it's a little bit more political
than just we vow revenge and we're going
to do it no matter what it takes
because there's there's a lot at stake
here with what they're trying to
accomplish
with the relationship they had with
obama which i'm sure they'll think will
continue with biden
and how trump uh treated them the last
four years
yeah i mean we talked about this a few
episodes ago about
solemnani we addressed this um i know
you've got some very strong
you said they're very proud people like
they're they're and they with a very
like long memories they're not just
gonna yeah let this race for impact
yes praise for impact you took out their
number two guy it's not a regular guy
you took out you took the guy that
uh was poised to one day replace the
leader of iran like this is a guy that
could have been
the president strategic connected guy
had
boots on the ground connected with the
soldiers connected with everybody in
iraq he had so many strong connections
and he was a strategic guy so
you take a guy like that out yeah like
like when they took out the nuclear
scientist their number one nuclear
scientist
you know he must have a good reason to
do it i mean trump doesn't have a
reputation of taking out
potential foreign leaders i mean there
must have been some serious reasons why
they had to do it
no i know i don't disagree i i do think
there was strong reasons to do it i just
think
they're also going to have strong
reasons to say we're coming back to
you know retaliate this what's going to
happen with this i pray to god nothing
well here's
the one thing at least with trump he
would warn them hey you try to do
anything about it you're gonna be you're
gonna regret it forever
i don't see biden making that similar
threat what's your prediction with iran
over the next uh
couple years they they're gonna do
something
and do they fear retaliation meaning are
they like holy [ __ ] if we do this
we're gonna have usa nato israel whoever
come after us
do they do they fear them at all well
who has iran's back now
russia who who else has iran's back now
what is it china
china's got iran's but you know china
you know how much money china invests
into iran
have you seen the number don't know do
you know the number no tell me it's a
it's a 400 billion dollar number type of
things we're not talking a small number
right yeah
so you know um yeah they're protected
now when you're protected like that you
got to be very careful if you go after
them because the protection is by people
that
are potentially the top threats to you
so you don't mess with them so they feel
a little bit more like
oh yeah i'm gonna call the gambino
family on you oh yeah okay come on say
something to me it's like that they have
protection now
right when you get protection you push
your weight a little bit say something
what do you got to say
go ahead so they're playing a little bit
aggressive and plus china has loyal
comrades because they pump so much money
to them they're indebted they have to
take their marching orders from whatever
china tells them to do what's china and
russia's relationship these days do you
know
um i don't know i mean i i i i haven't
read anything about it lately
i'm sure they're cautiously you know
watching each other they're on the
border yeah there you go china and iran
approach massive 400 billion
deal this is july 17 2020 china is going
to give you around 400 billion dollars
why is china missing to iran so
let me tell you man you got a
humanitarian yeah very humanitarian now
of course that's what it is humanitarian
so so you know again iran uh hope this
is a false alarm and nothing happens
with it but knowing them they have a
memory that they're going to come back
and want to do something about it i hope
i'm fully wrong
when i'm talking about this so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye